zugeschaltet aus berlin ist ulrike
herrmann von der tageszeitung taz für
das für nix nachgefragt von herrmann es
gab eine nachricht aus der nacht die
bisschen uns zeigt wie eng es eventuell
bald für russland werden könnte die
ratingagentur fitch
geht von einem
kurzfristigen zahlungsausfall von
russland aus also all das was jetzt auf
dem energiesektor passiert könnte
eventuell doch eng werden wie schätzen
sie es ein die amerikaner sind jetzt ein
schritt voran gegangen die frage ist wie
schnell folgen die europäer
also ich glaube nicht dass es so ist
dass die russen ihre verbindlichkeiten
im westen nicht bedienen könnten aus
zwei gründen sie haben fast keine
schulden im westen das ist ganz gering
russland vor dem krieg hatte immer
exportüberschüsse sie haben mehr
exportiert als importiert das heißt sie
haben eigentlich gar keine nennenswerten
auslandsschulden und sie nehmen ja auch
immer noch dollar ein in der form dass
wir gas und öl exportieren der punkt bei
fitch bei der ratingagentur ist dass man
eigentlich absehen kann dass die russen
einfach aufhören ihre schulden im
ausland zu bedienen nach dem motto ist
krieg der westen führt krieg gegen uns
durch diese sanktion jetzt schreiben wir
diese schulden sozusagen einfach mal
einseitig ab aber das ist nicht so dass
die russen jetzt gar kein geld mehr
hätten deswegen kommen ja diese debatten
in gang ob man jetzt öl und gas nicht
mehr importieren sollte genau diese
debatten sind im vollen gange sie sind
in deutschland nicht so massiv wie wir
sie bei den amerikanern bei den briten
jetzt direkt mit direkter konsequenz
erlebt haben dennoch sind sie da und auf
mittlere sicht vielleicht sogar auf
kürzere sicht will man das versuchen da
gibt es einen wirtschaftsminister der
auch für klimaschutz zuständig ist herrn
habig und der hat uns gestern wissen
lassen dass er lng terminals in tesla
geschwindigkeit bauen möchte wenn ich
mir das vor dem sammeln mal angesicht
des deutschen vergaberechts vorstelle
bin ich doch zumindestens begeistert vor
dieser herausforderung
also es wird bestimmt möglich seien
relativ schnell diese termine zu bauen
allerdings wird das spätestens dann im
nächsten winter aktuell der eigentliche
punkt ist ein völlig anderer also es ist
sehr sehr teuer gas mit schiffen zu
importieren ganz einfach weil man das
gas dann erstmal komprimieren muss man
muss kühlen das ist aufwendig der
schnellste weg gas zu importieren das
eben über pipelines und eigentlich ist
europa da auch gut aufgestellt weil die
wichtigsten gasfelder der welt sind alle
rund um europa also es war durchaus
schlau immer auf pipelines zu setzen
jetzt natürlich mit russland ist das
alles sehr schwierig aber ich glaube
dass man langfristig davon wegkommen
muss überhaupt gas zu benutzen nicht
also diese idee dass man vor allen
dingen die erneuerbaren energien jetzt
schnell ausbauen muss die ist absolut
richtig
ist richtig aber trotzdem nicht so
schnell durchführbar oder haben sind da
anders
nein aber ich glaube dass man sich etwas
sie sagen will ist man kann sich von dem
russischen gas nicht wirklich befreien
weil flüssiggas ist sehr teuer das ist
auch sehr schwierig zu transportieren
das heißt man ist auf die pipelines
angewiesen wenn man nicht erneuerbare
energien fördert dann muss man also doch
das ist das gas aus russland kaufen die
europäer haben uns ja gestern wissen
lassen die eu-kommission ganz konkret
dass sie also jetzt mit einer neuen
erdgas strategie an den start gehen die
ungefähr sagt dass man bis jahresende
2022 zwei drittel des russischen
erdgases was man bisher importiert
austauschen will für wie realistisch
halten sie das dass wir das einigermaßen
kostenneutrale umsetzen können das halte
ich finde ich möglich also man muss sich
das so klar machen dass weltweit die
energiemärkte komplett am limit sind und
das waren sie auch schon vor dem ukraine
krieg also es ist so dass es weltweit
mehr nachfrage gibt als angebot das gilt
sowohl für öl und das gilt für gas dann
und russland ist einer der wichtigsten
exporteure von öl und gas das heißt ohne
das russische öl ohne das russische gas
gehen die preise durch die decke das
kann man jetzt durchaus richtig finden
nach dem motto dann wird endlich mal
energie gespart man muss auch sagen dass
energie sehr stark verschleudert und
verschwendet wird ich sage nur ein suv
auf deutschen straßen es ist einfach die
totale energieverschwendung zwei tonnen
pro person das ist einfach quatsch aber
im augenblick ist nichts auf den
energiemärkten ein angebot noch übrig
das heißt wenn man die russen daraus
kicken will ist muss ganz klar sein das
muss sieben deutschen klar sein dass
dann energie sehr teuer wird und eben
nicht mehr so stark zur verfügung steht
wie bisher was ich gerne noch sagen
würde
dass ich in eine andere einschätzung
habe als viele zum thema wie finanziert
putin seinen krieg also es ist richtig
dass er im augenblick sehr viele dollar
einnimmt weil wir gas und öl von ihm
kaufen aber mit diesen dollar kann er ja
nichts anfangen es wird aus dem westen
praktisch nichts mehr geliefert und das
liegt ja nicht nur an den sanktionen
sondern das liegt auch daran dass zum
beispiel die großen reedereien wie
maersk die häfen in russland überhaupt
nicht mehr anfahren es gibt auch keine
flugzeuge mehr jedenfalls die meisten
linien sind gestrichen das heißt es
kommt einfach gar nichts mehr in
russland an und das jetzt haben wir den
völlig bizarren fall das gab es auch
noch nie in der weltgeschichte dass
russland ganz viel dollar hat damit aber
eigentlich nichts anfangen kann es ist
jedenfalls nicht so dass die dollar die
wir jetzt zahlen nach russland den krieg
finanzieren würden sondern der krieg in
der ukraine wird finanziert indem rubel
gedruckt werden und in dem es eine
inflation in russland gibt und
devisenhandel der gestern am späten
abend eingestellt wurde für eine geraume
zeit jetzt wenn wir die deutsche karte
zurück springen sie hatten der
verschiedene möglichkeiten offeriert was
man tun kann um energie zu sparen da war
sozusagen das große komfortable auto es
gibt auch besondere mal doch jetzt
dynamische vorschläge die sagen mach
doch einfach mal deine wohnung zwei grad
kälter
nicht jeder hält das für vorstellbar
aber ist es ungefähr das worauf wir uns
einstellen müssen und kann sich der
verbraucher darauf verlassen dass diese
bundesregierung preise abfedern wird
also man kann ja einmal tatsächlich ein
bisschen weniger heizen das ist schon
mal die idee ja
es ist auch richtig dass man die preise
abfedern muss aber nicht für alle also
es ist ja quatsch ist sie gut
verdienende mittelschicht zu entlasten
oder leute die in villen wurden sondern
man muss das gezielt machen also so dass
die leute die sehr wenig geld haben und
die sehr stark von diesen energiepreisen
getroffen werden dass die entlastet
werden aber jetzt nicht ganz deutschland
nicht und das geht auch gar nicht also
man muss sich einfach klarmachen
dass gas und öl wird deswegen teurer
weil es knapp ist und es war auch schon
vor der ukraine krise knapp jeder
erinnert sich dass es da auch schon
debatten über die gaspreise gab und man
kann nicht wenn etwas knapp ist denken
man kann einfach weiterhin so viel
konsumieren wie bisher also die
deutschen müssten sich darauf einstellen
dass energie nicht ständig vom himmel
fällt weniger fahren weniger heizen und
mit mehr vernunft mit energie umgehen
das war das bei ihnen von ulrike
herrmann von der tat ganz herzlichen
dank für die information ist
hintergründe im phoenix nachgefragt
danke ihnen